weren't you offered superman yeah at one
point were you offered to play the
christopher reeve role as superman but
you have to understand that that
when when superman was made it was
written by mario puzo and it was all
tongue-in-cheek it was hysterical right
hysterical right so because it's all
tongue-in-cheek so like when superman
first learns he can fly and he shows off
he does loop the loops and this and that
yeah and to
typicalize is that such a word sure
typical
tip i didn't ask about that one
they approach you about playing superman
right so now
i i read let me i want to give you an
example of when when lois when when
clark ken is just devastated because
she's in love with superman
physically the office is set up
in in the at the paper the daily planner
exactly right when if you go to in order
to get to clark kent's office you must
pass through lois lane's office i
understand to get there so there's no
other way in
so one day clark is so pissed off
because she's in love with superman he
goes out and screw it you know and he
this is just a typical scene the way it
was written there and he rips his
clothes off and he's got a superman
thing under there
and he goes lois come in here
she goes come on in here
so she comes in and she looks at him she
goes
that's sweet clark but
that's how it was yeah and then she
walks out and he goes looks in the
mirror he goes maybe a little talk here
a little i mean it was all tongue and
cheek why didn't they make the movie
would you assume because another
director did it and he did i mean you
know crystal reeves god bless him right
you know were you pissed that you didn't
get to play superman no because what
happened it was the salkin brothers and
they they said it was going to be two
movies now at the time i was very lucky
i could do whatever i want i could have
done
you know the phone book i was that big
right anyway
so i got a call from brando one night
how'd you make one you're gonna do this
picture with me i said
no no no no no i need some laughs
because i used to make a lamp like a
drop of actually christopher he wasn't
gonna make him laugh no no but that
wasn't the reason he said you got to do
this picture with me and today obviously
there was
a lot of that yeah but i said but fran i
said but well i can't use this was the
money or something no they paid me
plenty of money has nothing to do with
it
he says no no but come on i said you're
going to be there three and a half weeks
i'm there for like four months
what kind of laughs we're going to have
together you'll have your laughs and
you'll take off and you'll leave me
alone that's right so he says
no no no no we worked something out i
said marlon you know they're making two
movies out of it not one right you're
gonna make two he says so what i'm doing
it and i said yeah but you don't have to
wear the suit and he went
really hung up in a bird
[Laughter]